sur le président bonsoir monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues la
délégation sénatoriale aux outre-mer a
publié il y a tout juste 18 mois un
rapport très intéressant sur la
politique du logement dans les outre-mer
bien entendu la problématique de
l'habitat informel a retenu l'attention
de mes collègues et méritait d'être
débattu ici dans l'hémicycle aussi je
profite de l'occasion pour remercier le
président Artano pour cette initiative
ainsi que les rapporteurs Gontard l'URL
et Jacques pour le travail réalisé pour
répondre à la problématique du logement
d'outre-mer le Parlement adoptait
notamment novembre 2018 dans le cadre de
la loi Elan des dispositions spécifiques
à la Guyane et à Mayotte pour lutter
contre l'habitat informel le législateur
donne ainsi représentants de l'État de
Guyane et de Mayotte le pouvoir
d'ordonner aux occupants des habitats
informels d'évacuer les lieux et aux
propriétaires de procéder à la
démolition des structures dès lors
qu'elle présente des risques graves la
salubrité la sécurité ou la tranquillité
publique la nouveauté résidait dans le
fait que les préfets pouvaient ordonner
les démolitions sont passées par une
décision judiciaire nous pouvons le dire
la loi élan a suscité un formidable
espoir au sein de nos populations
éprouvées par le développement des
habitats sont droits
Guyane et Mayotte sont confrontés à
l'accroissement de l'habitat spontané
qui se développe sous la pression
démographique conséquence d'une très
forte immigration en Guyane un logement
sur quatre a été construit son droit
mythique à Saint-Laurent-du-Maroni
commune frontalière avec le Suriname
l'habitat informel représente 60% des
logements aussi dès que la mairie par
exemple envisage un projet de
construction le terrain est occupé il en
est de même pour une opération d'intérêt
national dont la mission première et
d'envoyer la dynamique du logement
informel et anticiper la démographie
galopante en créant près de 30000
logements d'ici 2030 paradoxalement de
nombre une zone d'habitat spontanée sont
installés sur le foncier appartenant à
l'État le premier propriétaire foncier
de Guyane l'impuissance de certains
acteurs ne rassure guère les petits
propriétaires qui ont se désagréables
sentiment d'être privé de leurs droits
mais aussi du fruit de leur dur labeur
l'ancienne mère que je suis a
fréquemment été confronté aux
difficultés liées à l'occupation
illégale de logement et au développement
de zone d'habitat informelle l'ancienne
mère que je suis a souvent eu intervenir
face à la colère des habitants des
propriétaires désabusés par les
occupations illégales de certains
bâtiments et de nos espaces publics et
en tant que mère je devais m'employer à
calmer l'exaspération des citoyens face
à l'inaction de l'État en 2018 alors
même que les parlementaires ici au Sénat
discutaient des contours de la loi Elan
une foule vindicative avait procédé des
logements d'une dizaine de familles d'un
squat à Cayenne et nous avons évité de
peu un drame alors moi aussi j'avais
placer beaucoup d'espoir dans cette loi
quatre ans après quel bilan pouvons-nous
tirer de cette loi en s'appuyant sur
l'article 197 de la loi Elan les préfets
de Guyane et de Mayotte ont certes
ordonné la démolition de plusieurs zones
d'habitat spontanées des opérations ont
permis de raser des dizaines de squats
où se côtoyer insalubrité misère et
insécurité mais nous devons avoir la
franchise de l'honnêteté de dire que ces
opérations n'ont malheureusement pas eu
le résultat escompté face à la pression
migratoire qui frappe ces deux
territoires et à la multiplication des
contentieux qui ralentissent ces
procédures plusieurs limites sont à
souligner à Mayotte comme en Guyane le
législateur a voulu au travers de cette
loi faciliter l'expulsion des occupants
de terrain sans droit anity mais le
passage de la théorie à la pratique est
bien plus complexe que prévu en effet
dans un élan humaniste le législateur à
conditionner les expulsions à des
propositions de relogement mais les préf
ne sont pas en mesure de proposer des
solutions de relogements famille par
conséquent les opérations d'évacuation
aboutissent systématiquement à la
reconstruction de nouvelles zones les
habitants r d'un squat à un autre
j'insisterai donc sur ce point la Guyane
n'est pas en mesure de proposer des
solutions de roulement aux habitants des
logiques en raison d'une offre de
logements quantitativement insuffisant
la Guyane n'est déjà pas en mesure de
répondre à la demande en matière de
logement de nos compatriotes et depuis
20 ans l'habitat informel progresse bien
plus vite que le logement légal par
conséquent je me réjouis de ce débat
mais également de l'examen demandé par
notre groupe RDPI de la proposition de
loi adoptée par l'Assemblée nationale
visant à protéger les logements contre
l'occupation illicite nous devons
chercher de nouvelles adaptations afin
que l'État de droit puisse exercer
pleinement en Guyane comme un Mayotte
mais aussi dans tous les territoires
face aux occupations illicites il n'est
pas acceptable que certains territoires
de la République continuent à livrer
seul ce combat contre l'habitat informé
pour conclure je voudrais rappeler ces
quelques mots de l'ancien président de
la République François Mitterrand en
déplacement officiel en Guyane en
septembre 1985 il s'était offusqué qu'on
continue à lancer des fusées sur fond de
bidonville près de 40 ans plus tard les
fusées décolle toujours les zones
d'habitat informel elle se multiplient à
la vitesse d'un lanceur au décollage
voilà Monsieur le Ministre rien n'a
changé depuis plus de 40 ans voilà ce
que je voulais exprimer